vous avez dit que la plupart des
réactions viennent de l'extérieur de
fessenheim
mais est ce que les habitants ne
fonctionne pas et mon potentiel de
connaissances pour je sais pas moi
évaluer les dangers qu'on la radio qui
sont la radioactivité ou mail à la
pollution thermique se disant est ce que
ce sont des données accessibles à eux
oui alors nous ne pouvons pas le juger
et contout risque
c'est certain il y en aura commun pour
toute l'industrie et dans cette mesure
je crois que je suis même d'avis et
qu'il faut faire confiance car nous
savons bien et techniciens et qu'ils
nous proposent leur programme
naturellement sous un certain contrôle
et à ce niveau ne pouvons peut que tirer
de l'expérience au niveau peu d'autres
sites ou le conseil municipal est quand
même allé se familiariser avec les dix
projets et où les élus les ont rassurés
puisque dans ce domaine nous avons quand
même déjà une expérience sur le plan
français d'une vingtaine d'années donc
en résumé pas
seul problème enfin on peut se poser
c'est l'histoire des déchets par sa
malle le problème des déchets ne vous
concerne pas tous a annoncé voilà n'est
pas concerné directement
est ce qu'il ya des comités contre la
centrale mais c'est un passionné mais
ils sont plus les alentours ce qui
essaie d'entraîner la population dans
leurs objectifs pas ce qu'était ce qui
était assez remarquable d'ailleurs c'est
qu'il ya eu une manifestation contre la
centrale nucléaire fait remonte à un an
et on a compté les gens de fonctionner
mais il y en avait peut-être trois ou
quatre du rsa venaient de suisse de les
environs de colmar strasbourg
qu'est-ce que c'était une réaction à
l'intéressé qui ça intéresse et non
politique
je suis une histoire de phénomènes
racisme c'est le noyau de base qui au
départ avaient manifesté et cali essayer
de sensibiliser ceux qui te reprocher
tout le monde s'est retrouvé dans le
sinaï mais jeudi il y avait très peu de
la région il y avait ils se retrouvaient
depuis un voyage ne sais pas où au moins
200 km 1
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je resterai ça peut savoir qu est ce qu
a connues mobilisé sept la centrale
alors c'est aux serres refroidissement
des condenseurs de la centrale il y a
deux tranches donc en construction et
qui entreront en service dans quelques
mois dire que les centrales nucléaires
rejeter de l'eau chaude est ce que ça
peut nuire à la fronde que je vous en
passer alors l'eau de refroidissement
était chauffée de l'ordre de 8 à 10
degrés dans la centrale la marche
nominal et il faut noter je dirais une
heureuse particularité de la du site de
fessenheim
c'est que un kilomètre en amont de cette
centrale il ya une centrale hydraulique
c'est à dire que l'eau est chauffée qui
est rejoint dans le canal airs mélangés
par le turbinage des machines ce qui
fait que à la sortie de l'usiné
l'échauffement moyens et varie du 10e à
2 degrés est encore une autre
particularité du haut débit du rhin le
rhin à les débits les plus forts en été
c'est à dire dans une saison qui serait
le plus défavorable vis-à-vis
d'échauffement maintenant on voit deux
grands bâtiments en béton l'avant
battant ce qu'on peut savoir ce que
c'est justement alors les deux bâtiments
de forme cylindrique abrite les
chaudières nucléaires c'est à dire les
réacteurs 6h30 cuillère et d'argent
russe ce qu'elle pourrait rejeter des
radiations l'extérieur sous des arbres
aussi monsieur leblond oui bien sûr une
centrale nucléaire comme fessenheim en
jette à l'extérieur à la fois des
effluents gazeux par la cheminée blanche
et rouge que vous voyez entre les deux
bâtiments réacteurs
elle rejette également des effluents
liquides qui sont mélangés à l'eau de
refroidissement des condenseurs et qui
sont rejetés donc dans le canal d'alsace
ce polluant c
nous avons étudié les conséquences de
ces rejets sur l'environnement en vue
d'obtenir l'autorisation de rejet et il
en résulte une augmentation de la
radioactivité ceci en se plaçant dans
les conditions les plus pessimistes donc
une augmentation qui est de l'ordre de 1
200e de la radioactivité naturelle dans
la région de fessenheim envisagez-vous
le problème des déchets il ya deux
sortes de déchets à considérer il y as
je dirais les déchets qui sont produits
sur place qui résultent de
l'exploitation de la centrale
ils ne représentent pas de très gros
volumes disons quelques dizaines de
mètres cubes et qui sont faiblement
actifs donc ceci ne pose pas à mon avis
de problèmes de stockage tout au moins
pas de gros problèmes le problème le
plus difficile c'est le stockage des
déchets qui résulte du retraitement du
combustible et ce retraitement
actuellement effet l usine enfin prévu
ce qui concerne fessenheim être fait à
l'usiné
blague et c'est là je pense que le
problème se pose où il faudra trouver à
terme des solutions qui permettent de
stocker en toute sécurité ses déchets
ce qui suppose des installations qui
aujourd'hui n'existe pas mais dont on
connaît déjà les les principes
[Musique]
on
ça c'est du passé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans cette étude
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]